si vous avez plus de vingt ans vous ne
savez peut-être pas ce qu'est tik tok
réseau social à la mode chez les jeunes
qui en quelques années a pris la place
d'instagram et de snapshot dans les
téléphones des adolescents un sujet
auquel s'intéressait hier soir
l'émission complément d'enquêté
pourtant tik tok n'est pas un réseau
social particulièrement adapté un jeune
public est basé sur des courtes
séquences vidéo en musique les contenus
sexy ou parfois violents peuvent s'y
trouver
et pour les parents qui ne connaissent
pas l'application difficile de contrôler
et je pense qu'il recherchait incertaine
chasse de l'attention ou surtout que le
phénomène n'est pas petit 50% des 11 à
12 ans utilisent régulièrement tik tok
et c'est bien là le problème
ce jeune public livré à lui même qui
postent des vidéos suggestif de en train
de danser il cible facile pour les
pédophiles
malte monde de l'ombre et d'oignons ou
des photos de nombreux prédateurs
sexuels créerait de faux comptes pour
échanger avec des mineurs sous défaut
d'identité votre problème les arnaques
en ligne certains membres de tik tok
avec des millions d'abonnés n'hésiterait
pas à soutirer de l'argent à des fans en
échange de quelques minutes de
discussion avec eux des fans souvent
trop jeunes pour se rendre compte de ces
abus alors arnaquer dérive
le réseau social tik tok les petites
dangereux pour nos enfants
[Musique]
j'espère vous nous suivez en famille que
même les plus jeunes sont avec nous
voilà ce soit parce qu'on pourrait leur
expliquer tik tok c'est très bien mais
il ya vraiment des écueils à éviter
et merci claire charles d'être avec nous
présidente de l'association les
effrontés selon-vous tik tok représente
un vrai danger notamment pour les
mineurs vous allez nous expliquer
pourquoi dans un instant il ya plus qu'à
et merci d'être là non merci d'être là
c'est dans laquelle il a un amour et tu
kartonn 7 jean-mi d'abonnés sur titres à
plus de 14 millions de light et toi pour
le coup je trouve que tu utilises bien
tik tok mars parce que voilà on se fait
des trucs sympathiques bon délire et
voilà c'est ce qu'on quitte moi c'est
pour des gens comme toi aussi que je
kiffe tik tok voilà je voulais je
voulais je voulais te le dire alors vous
clair vous êtes penser que tik tok
c'est vraiment un vrai danger pour les
mineurs alors c'est un danger
actuellement c'est à dire que nous on
n'est pas pour la suppression de ce
réseau social
je tiens à dire que nous on est une
association qui s'aiment beaucoup sur
les réseaux sociaux donc on n'est pas du
tout content les réseaux sociaux par
contre il ya un gros problème au niveau
de l'algorithme du contrôle parental
justement là on a les missions à
complément d'enquêté qui reprend des
choses que nous on avait déjà vu chez le
youtube heures le roi des rats qui a
fait une super enquête où il a pu
vérifier que le contrôle parental ne
marchait pas du tout c'est à dire que
vous avez par exemple la possibilité
pour les parents de mettre en accès
restreint des comptes de leurs enfants
c'est à dire que les enfants ne peuvent
pas accéder à tous les contenus savoir
que sur tik tok et des contenus
pornographiques mais vraiment
pornographiques nature voilà je suis bon
je vous montrais puisque premier exemple
avec toutes les scènes choquantes
il ya beaucoup de cette choquante de
nudité de sexe paroles très crues que
l'on peut trouver sur cette application
la journaliste d'enquêté de complément
d'enquêté a réalisé qu'elle s'est
inscrite sur la pluie comme si elle
avait 13 ans et regardez le contenu que
l'application du propos de regarder je
vais créer un compte tictoc comme si
j'avais 13 ans
treize ans c'est l'âge minimum légal
pour s'inscrire sur tik tok aucune
vérification
voici sans aucune coupe le contenu
proposé à un nouvel utilisateur de
treizistes au bout d'une minute
une jeune femme plutôt aguicheuse suivi
immédiatement d'une autre une minute 56
plus tard bonjour comment est ce qu'on
fait pour avoir une belle voiture dans
la vie là-bas on se prostituent bois de
boulogne le soir bois de l'ancienne la
journée puis voilà on a une belle
voiture
toutes ces vidéos me sont suggérées par
l'algorithme de tik tok cette
intelligence artificielle ne connaît
rien d'autre que mon âge 13 ans voilà ce
que vous disiez un clerc charles
c'est ça qui pose vraiment vraiment
vraiment problème c'est qu'on peut avoir
accès très rapidement à des vidéos et
très choquant pour des enfants voilà qui
ont 13 ans ou en moi je le sais et moi
j'ai interdit voilà l'extrême les
enfants adeptes à qui l'on doit la 8 et
9 ans et ils veulent absolument être
sorti
alors c'est pas le seul souci le l'autre
problème c'est qu'en fait vous avez des
enfants parfois très jeunes donc ils
n'ont même pas très grande et petite
fille de 8 ans qui postent elle même des
contenus qui sont très sexualisée il
s'en fait tant aux proies en proie aux
prédateurs qui viennent leur demander
leur téléphone leur snapshot etc et il
n'y a pas du tout contrôle de tik tok à
ce niveau là en fait il n'ya pas non
plus de contrôle parental parce que moi
les parents s'ils le pouvaient avoir
accès à un historique
en fait dès de ce que font les vite les
enfants mais pourrait tout de suite dire
bah non ça c'est pas possible alors
c'est exactement ce que disait on va
voir le témoignage de sa team qui est
avec loca saison elle va vous raconter
ce qui lui est arrivé le fait qu'on le
puisse s'y inscrire dès 13 ans et qu'on
y trouve beaucoup d'adolescents en tic
toc un terrain de chasse favori pour
certains adultes avec de mauvaises
intentions
écoutez le témoignage assez fort de ce
policier qui est en charge de la
criminalité sur le web regarder
malheureusement ces positions là à 10
ans on est déjà dans un but de séduction
même si elles imitent des adultes il
suffit que dans les personnes qui
reçoivent la proposition de cet
algorithme vous ayez un adulte acquis
cette petite plaie il va se connecter en
tant qu'ami va commencer à mettre plein
de nike et à ouvrir une discussion
les parents seront jamais au courant que
leur enfant qui a 9 ans ou dix ans est
en train de communiquer avec un adulte
qui a qu'une intention c'est la faire se
déshabille
et les pédophiles ils ont là un but
c'est d'entrer en contact avec la
personne là l'enfant qui a posté cette
vidéo et ils vont la pousser à faire
autre chose vraiment c'est leur terrain
c'est leur terrain de chasse favori et
alors lucas était avec moi alors lui
c'est vrai que quand je le vois quand je
vois ce qui fait lui il est a dit samedi
lumière de ce qui peut se passer sur tik
tok lui ils utilisent très bien fait des
vidéos vraiment moi la coquille
c'est vrai que voilà moi c'est ça que
j'aime / tik tok et fuqua tu vas voir le
témoignage de sa team tu vas dire c'est
un carré blanc bouffe gens ni deux nous
on n'est pas du tout dans ce délire
document on veut on peut faire des
vidéos tu fais déjà vu aussi
effectivement mais faire attention c'est
aux enfants mais j'aimerais bien écouté
des témoignages
alors justement alors satine toi bâton
ta saison aujourd'hui un coup tu me
racontes nous ce qui s'est passé éclaire
charles vous allez voir le témoignage de
sa team death et c'est forcément pas la
seule
et c'est une porte parole de ce qui peut
se passer sur titres alors non
effectivement je suis très très loin
avec la salle et c'est ça qui est bien
malheureux donc en fait je venais de
faire ce week end il y avait une
certaine notoriété qui se construisait
du coup autour de moi et il se trouve
que du coup je m'étais mise à faire des
tic toc c'était les tout débuts de tik
tok je m'en souviens très bien parce que
ça me faisait énormément
donc je me suis dis pas je vais faire
comme tout le monde je vais faire un
étiquetage j'en fais je fais des
compilations que je publie sur ma chaîne
youtube et à partir de là j'ai eu
énormément de pédophiles qui sont venus
vers moi qui m'appelait qui m'envoyaient
des vidéos de masturbation des photos
comme en face alors commencé à arriver
tout de suite c'est vraiment c'est alors
en fait l'histoire c'est que moi j'étais
très jeune
vraiment faim très jeune dans le sens où
la glace j'avais 11 12 ans et orio parce
qu'on disait c'est vrai qu'il ya des
enfants plus jeunes qui ont accès
direction etc etc c'est le problème
j'avais wayne toussaint est en fait
c'est terrible quand on reçoit ça quand
on a 11 12 ans comprend pas forcément
sais même pas ce que c'est vraiment la
sexualité on sait tout juste et en fait
c'est ma mère qui gérait mais comptent
souvent et je les gérer aussi de temps
en temps et quand on tombait dessus avec
ma mère on en rigolait beaucoup parce
que c'était la seule manière en fait
pour moi de pas vraiment resté
traumatisé de tout ça même si quelque
part ça me marque énormément je recevais
des messages des choses des choses
terribles en fait mais de personnes
vraiment très âgées il ya même temps
vraiment décrire mais quel genre de
choses pour voilà pour qui
une demande est des vidéos de montres
m'a masturbé et c'est alors que j'avais
vraiment 12 ans et c'était vraiment part
je pense il devait y avoir bien une
cinquantaine de personnes voire house
ah ouais c'était et on a même porté
plainte voilà par exemple parce que
quelqu'un sur twitter divulguer toutes
les informations personnelles est menacé
en me disant j'ai des vidéos de toi nu
devant ta webcam quand tu ne changes
quand tu sors de la douche je me
masturbe dessus je vais les poster etc
si tu ne sais pas si tu ne fais pas ça
on a porté plainte on n'a plus de
nouvelles de cette personne n'a encore
heureux et c'est terrible c'est terrible
pour un enfant de 12 ans de vivre ça et
je suis très très loin d'être la seule
et tik tok est vraiment l'un enfin c'est
vraiment le centre en fait d'un de tout
un réseau de pédophilie mais énorme et
c'est vraiment traumatisant je trouve
enfin de savoir que ça existe où je sais
c'est terrible quand j'avais j'avais des
amis qui ont été dans mon fluence heures
j'ai en tout cas j'ai une amie à moi qui
ai tic toc euse et qui fait aussi face
au problème du coût de
l'hypersexualisation j'ai des amis même
pas forcément connus qui reçoivent aussi
des vidéos comme ça et c'est donc ce
n'est pas que tik tok
mais là en tout cas on parle de tik tok
et c'est vraiment un vrai problème et
c'est quelque chose où il faut agir au
plus vite parce que l'hyper
sexualisation et constante sur tik tok
constamment voit que les gens réagissent
beaucoup sur ce sujet si vous nous
rejoignez sur s'est vite c'est
incroyable ton témoignage un satine toi
tu as eu la chance aussi détecte à maman
et ma maman voilà soyez pas ce qu'elle
gère t compte et c'est bien aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui
2 de shon
voilà très très jeunes gens qu'ils en
finir leur truc tout seul et qui vont se
retrouver face à des vidéos ou des
demandes comme ça exact et qui vont pas
savoir quoi faire et qui peuvent être
traumatisés à vie vraiment aux as et
c'est extrêmement grave donc je si les
parents nous regarde vraiment essayé de
checker l'incident tik tok l'exacte
voilà des vidéos qui sont envoyées à vos
enfants les messages parce que c'est
vrai que ça thinel attachant c'est que
ce qu'elle voulait voir ses parents ils
sont toujours avec l île à ce jour il a
lâché moi mais il ya des enfants qui
sont pas aussi entouré et les parents
ils ont les fausses confiance voilà ils
sont moins présents et ça peut amener
ces trucs qui me choque c'est que quand
vous allez sur un sig ii
jeux en ligne on vous demande le
passeport la cadence qui tenait une
facture de edf gdf et donc vous êtes
tracé pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait passer
pourquoi est ce que les parents
pourraient pas cautionner un compte où
les gens qui s'inscrivent avec passeport
canosi était saturé nef et y aura plus
de problème je le poison de tout ça
parce que il ya des choses très bien sur
les réseaux enfin voilà et c'est un
tremplin pour lui au contraire tu vois
feuq ait ôté tout le contraire bah oui
cocon à moi qui ai envie enfin voilà que
les banques vraiment l'histoire des
petits jeunes et regarde les jeunes
quant à moi j'ai envie d'être comme toi
moi la voile et même les petits jeunes
qui traînent mon fils qui passait ce que
tu fais greek tu vois tu t'es des trucs
à celle de 6 ans c'est le principal en
fait il faut nous on dégage vraiment la
bonne humeur la joie différents modes
smile c'est ça doit être ça c'est ça
c'est ça le problème je vais te montrer
tout de suite c'est que sur tik tok si
tu fais une vidéo drôle tu vas pas buzz
et wave in situ dénude tu vas être mise
en avant exaltante sur la place à ses
chats qui a cédé 1,15 claire regarder la
première vidéo publiée sur le compte de
cette jeune fille a récolté 16 me like
c'est mignon même si elle veut augmenter
son nombre d'abonnés il va falloir
qu'elle en fasse encore plus ça peut pas
être ça veut pas se limiter à ça quatre
mois plus tard voici ce que la jeune
fille met en ligne
on voit que la variable celle ci elle a
fait 3 millions de vues et oui et oui
c'est très simple la vidéo pourquoi elle
fait 3 millions de vues moi en tant qu'
en tant que flic il voit tout de suite
le pourquoi vous avez vous avez une
vidéo qui a un côté sexuel immédiat
c'est ça le problème
moi mais c'est pareil avec moi aussi
j'ai fait j'ai fait un test dernièrement
ouais j'assume j'ai posté une dizaine de
vidéos normal ok elles n'ont pas trop
marché et ensuite j'ai fait un proc dans
la rue avec juste une couverture une
miniature de cliquer avec deux personnes
qui s'embrassent automatiquement à la
minute même à 7 conspué plus mis en
avant aussi quand le temps était plus
mise en avant aussi sur le position de
fait ceux sur le fait que les deux
personnes 100 brasse en train miniature
près directement aux n'est plus mis en
avant et ça et surtout par rapport aux
fibres en fait ces opus saison de like
ou plus ça continue herman
que ça sur le net que ce genre de choses
c'est pas juste l'algorithme c'est la
nature des vidéos que tu proposes qui va
attirer un certain nombre de bien sûr
c'est exactement la même chose sur
instagram par exemple tu mets des photos
et des barrages partout lui deadline et
plus tu exact l'algorithme pour sortir
aller là où tik tok kesha est assez moi
je trouve enfin fait semblant de fait
semblant d'essayer de régler le problème
c'est que là ils ont annoncé qu'ils
allaient rendre les comptes des moins de
16 ans privé et seuls les 13 15 ans
pourrait y aller pour moi demain si je
décide que j'ai 13 ans je m'inscris et
je dis que j'ai 13 ans et je pourrai
accéder à ses comptes soient des gens
veulent des solutions quoi oui ça tu ne
voulais ajouter quelque chose non mais
en fait le problème c'est que l'hyper
sexualisation est constante dans l'oc
société encore plus sur tik tok
sauf que l'hyper sexualisation tik tok
c'est pas le seul problème de réseau
social concerné c'est qu'il ya aussi
beaucoup de romans tiza sion je peux
citer le terme romantique à sion mais de
drogue de suicide également
d'automutilation est en fait les
personnes sur ce réseau d'ailleurs c'est
l'un des réseaux en fait qui est le
peuple est de plus de mineurs en fait de
vraiment qui concerne un public très
jeune et ces personnes-là jeunes sont
très influençables et directement se
mutiler va être une mode devenir
lesbienne ou bi va devenir une mode etc
et très facilement en fait ça fait le
tour de tik tok et c'est terrible et
c'est pas le seul problème il ya aussi
celui des live celui des live qui
concernent énormément d'arnac etc ou des
enfants pareil très influent en manque
d'attention directement vont vouloir de
l'attention sur les live vont dépenser
des centaines sont pas des centaines de
milliers d'euros mais en tout cas des
milliers d'euros de la carte bancaire de
leurs parents et c'est terrible pour
avoir plus de followers ou de like
certains sont prêts à dépenser des
sommes folles ils doivent acheter des
petits cadeaux virtuels avec de l'argent
réel et parfois ça va loin regarder
certains d'influenceurs arnaque même des
jeunes pour gagner de l'argent c'est pas
du tout ce que fait de fugue avec bien
sûr un gain jamais fait de la guerre
permet pas aux mineurs de dépenser de
l'argent sur l'application mais rien ne
les empêche de mentir sur leur âge pour
contourner cette interdiction contre
baroin sa bonne âme ou en fait une
donner de la visibilité quoi dès que le
garçon cesse de donner de l'argent
les influenceurs reviennent à la charge
il l'appelle directement sur son
téléphone sur indre hamas a coûté 54
euros 99 donc de drama ça coûtait 100
requêtes avant tout vous estimez qu'il
allait lancer combien pour faire des
clés de votre chance
j'ai pas content et je veux pas savoir
3400 way we satine je souhaite
l'histoire c'est que tout le monde y est
du coup mais tic tac n'a qu'à supprimer
cette fonctionnalité vu qu'elle est si
problématique pour plan de personnes
cette petit tacle à la supprime rien
jamais alors à la merci beaucoup trop
d'argent
ça en fait il se trouve qu'au niveau des
statistiques donc si un influenceur va
faire un live
quelqu'un va par exemple donc un enfant
un mineur quelqu'un de très influençable
va donner un autocollant qui va coûter
environ 16 euros
c'est vrai qu'on peut en avoir huit
euros pour leurs frères et soeurs et 8
euros pour tik tok qui en fait c'est 50
et donc c'est diviser en deux donc ça
rapporte énormément d'argent à tik tok
donc jamais ils vont supprimer
du coup cette fonctionnalité moi j'ai
une autre j'ai un autre extrait je
voulais vous montrer ce que vous
réagissiez lassus claire charles parce
que on se demande s'il devrait pas y
avoir un c'est ça des réseaux et le
tictoc parce que kim a énormément choqué
la ccpt pas dans complément d'enquêté
c'est que ces jeunes disent leurs
opinions en toute liberté
mais beaucoup disent d'énormes bêtises
qu'ils peuvent être punis par la loi
voilà si on les dit voilà à la
télévision par exemple
c'est le cas de cet adolescent dont on
préservera l'identité qui tient des
propos vraiment d'une violence extrême
et des propos vraiment vous allez voir
voilà très très très raciste
et ça pour moi ça m'a profondément
choqué et c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il devrait y avoir un csa de tik tok
parce que ça c'est inadmissible regarder
oui je vous fait d'eux des manières à
des fonds d africains à dire non faut
pas refaire le mc st
de basses et des cobayes ce taiseux ses
esclaves donc si on va leur faire les
vaccins en fait arrêté puis face on peut
être d'accord ou pas personnellement moi
je vous emmerde alors sur facebook avec
dans les conditions d'utilisation ils se
réservent le droit d'enlever des
contenus inappropriés
tandis que là sur ces vidéos elles ne
sont pas filtrées
on peut tout voir donc c'est là c'est là
la différence je trouve avec facebook ou
alors que les différents réseaux ça vu
cette vidéo vous avez la balle on fait
chauffer en personne en fait c'est que
justement même facebook quand on signale
des contenus inappropriés construira si
les enlève pas c'est à dire que c'est là
c'est le nombre qui sait que un contenu
de leur supprimer ça si moi je suis je
signale un contenu porno ou misogyne ça
va pas de supprimer par contre il ya 30
personnes qui va se mouiller un contenu
qui est pourtant pas illégal ça peut
être supprimés alors que ça n'a rien
d'illégal juste parce que le nombre à
les en fait en fait c'est nous c'est les
utilisateurs concon signal est clair
c'est que ça supprime alors il ya aussi
des robots qui supprime ottomane à ce
jour sur instagram comme sur tik tok ce
que moi j'ai déjà eu un compte
un petit peu agressifs qu'ils ont qu'ils
ont dit comme justification qui a été
supprimé mais il ya aussi des robots
c'est pas toujours les gens qui me le
signalent chômage aurait montré à
dernier extrait dans le reportage on a
pu aussi voir la french alors j'aime
beaucoup ce qu'ils font c'est un groupe
de jeunes en colocation tu connais bien
sûr un feu car oui bien sûr dans une
très belle villa ce sont des stars sur
tik tok qui font du placement de produit
et certains sont prêts à faire des
kilomètres pour venir voir ces jeunes
stars qui gagnent énormément d'un an
donc ça s'est mis un décor de rêve
le château de 13 c près d'angers ils
sont jeunes ils sont beaux et ils
adorent tik tok la french house une
sorte de marque de la belle qui regroupe
ses neuf tic toc heures au moment de
notre tournage il fallait débourser
entre 10000 et 25000 euros pour une
collaboration réunissant l'ensemble de
la french house
tous les fans ne reste pas derrière leur
écran certains font des kilomètres pour
voir leur idole en vrai vous aimeriez
être comme eux oui oui de connu et
rooney faire des photos entre faire une
photo avec brad pitt ou avec la frenchie
préférée qui voit là on l'a vu au
travail a des bons côtés et qui
fabriquent tous les autres qui le suit
pas suivez le parce qu'il est marginal
était un amour de mecs là si on fait
autant passer de ma part c'est beaucoup
et merci claire charles merci d'avoir
été là également et on suit tout ça et
si vous voulez revenir nous voir
n'hésitez pas